[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony
michaels hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
welcome to the show
today is kind of a weird day
in history
it will
be known as a very historic day
and a historic time in uh our country
and the world
where there is one party in our country
in our democracy that is supporting a
murderous dictators uh absolute
unjustified invasion of another country
uh an ally of ours not necessarily a
nato ally uh nato um seems to be
stepping up it doesn't seem as if
they're ready to send troops yet this
morning um as there's
reports and we're gonna watch some video
i know we were gonna play the interview
about the
uh data dump from the um ottawa convoy
but seeing is with the news the way it
is today
with possibly
maybe a third
world type war or a second cold war
starting um we are going to
put that on the burner for now and we
are going to cover the
news in ukraine where vladimir putin
that murderous [ __ ] dictator
is
100
100
percent
being a tyrant this is what tyrants do i
said this yesterday i think i said it
the day before and the day after that
and of course uh gabe yesterday uh he's
going to be on the show today and i
think he's going to be as gabe we
definitely want to commentate on this
seriously yesterday we used satire a
little bit um as gabe
booked or appeared as vladimir putin on
the show you can go back and watch that
on the youtube channel but it is it is
uh very very very important stuff now
this is serious if you know we like to
make fun we like to have fun we like to
joke around the hahas and the funnies
this is very [ __ ] serious stuff more
than just uh vladimir putin that
murderous dictator tyrant
invading a country that he has no right
to invade um article four seems to be uh
enacted at this point um it looks like
there could be article five coming from
nato um as he borders belarus
um because that is part of the danger to
the nato allies is the country that's
that he's bordering
with his invasion
so we will see there's a lot of stuff
that
in the trends about this not only
afghanistan uh ukraine belarus
several countries the middle east
because some are comparing
the last time the article 5
of nato was enacted which was
right after 9 11 i believe it was
september 12th or september 15th or
excuse me september 12th or september
13th uh when article 5 the last time it
was reenacted by nato
um to push back on a an invasion or an
attack
um that it was an imminent attack so we
have we have all these things
going on this morning
and i appreciate you guys joining us uh
debbie's here david patty ann uh anne's
here jay's here yoda's here um
mj's here thank you very much you guys
for joining us
uh stay with us because again gabe's
gonna be here today i've invited a few
other people now i'm not sure at their
schedules if they can come on and give
some of their commentary but hopefully
if we can't get them on today we will
get them on in future episodes so you
can hear some of that commentary as well
some people who know a little more about
ukraine i i really honestly
other than the news that we've had and
the
the news that we had before in this
arena of ukraine um that's about all i
know um some people are saying today
that oh if trump was
you know for the last [ __ ]
month two months almost
we have we have
a party in our country the the
republican party now the gqp
the death cult
deciding to side with putin
here and acting like he's the strong man
and he's justified well as soon as he
actually started throwing rockets and
bombs and [ __ ] they've changed their
[ __ ] tune now it's all biden's weak
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
the media the media and and the
republican party has been basically
[ __ ] mocking the bite administration
for saying hey russia is going to do
this they're going to do this vladimir
putin is going to do this he's going to
throw rockets and bombs and [ __ ]
and we're going to show you some video
here today
of not only helico helicopter attacks
but also rocket attacks in ukraine some
of that footage is on twitter we're
going to show it here
on the tony michaels podcast i'm not
sure what the consequences are over on
other platforms like youtube and that
sort of thing but we're gonna [ __ ]
show it i'm not gonna hide that [ __ ]
we're gonna look at it we're gonna see
it i think it's important to see on the
ground what this looks like now
be aware that a lot of this stuff is on
twitter so getting it verified is very
difficult um so anything that we show
here we want you to understand i am not
a newsmaker i am not a newscaster
i just commentate on the news and i
commentate on twitter post
so i will look at these
as best i can we will look at them i
will commentate and we will commentate
on the situation on the ground in
ukraine
based on what we can see on social media
that's the best we can do
and then that's all we can do
but at this point it does appear that
vladimir putin has decided to have a hot
war in ukraine not just a cold war which
is more than likely to start a cold war
with us and possibly our nato allies
um we will we will see what the result
will be as we tick along here
and how that will happen but
it seems to be that vladimir putin
thinks that his best play to remain in
power
is to test democracy and test the will
of democracy because i believe again as
i've said over and over and over again i
believe that's the one thing that
vladimir putin sees is his biggest enemy
is democracy and this is a pattern of
tyrants
right
tyrants do this tyrants die that's how
it works the world and democracy is
generally intolerant of intolerance and
they will not tolerate someone murdering
and killing innocent people because they
want to remain in power
and that's just just not what america is
going to do that's not what the western
democracy world is going to do now
rather you you believe in the western
democracy with capitalism
and things of that nature well you know
that's a whole other [ __ ] ball game
here we're not talking about economic
systems we're not talking about
oppressing and suppressing and and and
discriminating against people
in this in this situation we're talking
about war life death war
and one man wanting an authoritarian a
totalitarian
authoritarian a murderous [ __ ]
dictator a tyrant trying to remain in
power because i believe that's what's
happening because we also see videos not
just of ukraine but also of russia that
there are no anti-war um protests
breaking out in russia and they're
arresting these people on the spot
and the reason why they're arresting
these people on the spot is because they
do not want this to take hold in russia
because i believe that the the russian
people would be better off with
democracy that's why they lock up alexey
navalny
because putin knows that the that the
russian people would be better with
democracy that's the threat
that's the [ __ ] threat that's why the
gqp is with that [ __ ]
democracy is not their friend it is
their
enemy they have no ideas they have no
policies for equality and equity for all
for human humanity for [ __ ] sake
you don't have to go line by line in a
[ __ ] bill we don't have to we don't
have to tear apart our entire judicial
system our entire legislative system our
entire administrative system to
understand that the fundamentals of
democracy
that the majority of ideology should
dictate how a country is governed
regardless of the country regardless of
the borders regardless of the people who
live inside those borders black white
brown muslim christian atheist it
doesn't [ __ ] matter
and vladimir putin throwing rockets and
bombs into a country killing innocent
people and trying to in trying trying to
invoke war with western democracy
we should see as a war against all of us
and our ideas
that's what we should see it as and
there are people in this country who are
[ __ ] rooting for him
now they're tucking tail and turning
because
they thought he was too much of a [ __ ]
to do what he's doing but they they
don't see tyrants as tyrants because
they are them
you had the [ __ ] former guy stand on
stage last night in front of a
microphone and deep throat vladimir
putin giving him [ __ ] fellatio
that [ __ ] traitor that's right
donald trump is a [ __ ] traitor and he
should be treated as such that
[ __ ]
never in our history has a president of
the united states especially a formal
one stand on stage in front of a
microphone and say the [ __ ] he was
saying about an enemy who is trying to
tear down not just our democracy but
western democracy in general which if
you believe in america and american
ideas
and you're a [ __ ] patriot
the idea that american the doctrine that
american can spread democracy all around
the world that we're the we're the
highlight we're the shining we're the
shining city on the hill
you [ __ ]
can you tell i'm sick of this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
maybe they'll get their [ __ ] act
together now that they realize that
vladimir putin is exactly what vladimir
putin is none of this pussyfooting
around and pretending none of this
professional wrestling [ __ ] anymore this
is not the intersection of wrestlemania
and real life this is real [ __ ] life
my friend
real [ __ ] life get your [ __ ] act
together quit [ __ ] getting on your
goddamn knees and giving donald trump
and vladimir putin fellatio it's enough
of this [ __ ] [ __ ] with these goddamn
tyrants
these want to be [ __ ] dictators
these authoritarians it's enough of this
[ __ ] pluck your head out of your [ __ ]
asses
whatever you got to do get off social
media stop watching [ __ ] fox news
stop watching newsmax unplug from oan
you dumb [ __ ]
they're duping you they're duping you
into [ __ ] following tyrants who will
kill you
we see images we see images of the
troops in russia hauling a portable
crematorium
to cremate their bodies to hide the body
count
got it
they don't give a [ __ ] about you
that's the best part about being an
authoritarian
is they don't have to give a [ __ ] about
anybody but their own power
and that's it
but that's how tyrants end
that's what happens to them this is the
pattern that happens
if you've done any history and any
studying
on nazi germany or italy for that matter
or japan
during the second world war
you would know you would know very
clearly very [ __ ] clearly
that authoritarians totalitarianism only
ends with the tyrant at the end of a
rope are dead in a bunker
go look at it and you can give examples
all around the world
even in the middle east
go i challenge you
our democracy
our democracy affords
that a former leader
has the right to live
has the right to live out their life
even if it's a life of crime for [ __ ]
sake what we're seeing right now in this
country
but these trump pumping americans better
pluck their heads out of their [ __ ]
asses and realize that they're being
duped into loving their own cheeto dust
vladimir putin
you stupid bastards
it's enough of this [ __ ] it's enough of
this un-american unpatriotic [ __ ]
you [ __ ] being against american and
allied soldiers
against innocent people being killed by
vladimir putin in the russian army
you [ __ ]
we're gonna go to the shitless roundup
here
i promise again i if you're just joining
us we were gonna play the interview
about the uh the data leak um of the
ottawa trucker convoy but we have moved
that and the reason why is because the
news about ukraine and russia
i feel like but it is much more
important to talk about that today as
it's happening
we could comment commentated on it
tomorrow but we could also play the
interview tomorrow or monday so we are
going to put that on hold as we talk
about
russia and ukraine
and we will probably talk about russia
and ukraine tomorrow as well
i'm sure this news is not going to go
anywhere fast so i've got a lot of video
i want to show you uh of what seems to
be happening on the ground there in
ukraine and we will try to make some
sense of it which you know none of this
is going to make sense i also want to
show you the video of the the cheeto
dust traitor that [ __ ] traitor
standing in front of a microphone giving
fellatio to vladimir putin deep
throating that [ __ ] in front of
a crowd of other sycophants those pieces
of [ __ ] [ __ ]
why the hell wouldn't every single one
of them get up and walk out well the
reason why is because they're [ __ ]
traitors they're un-american they're not
patriots you [ __ ]
so let's let's get to it let's get to
the countdown start it up
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the list
roundup where we ran up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends of today
and boy do we have a lot a lot a lot a
lot of [ __ ] news for you a ton of
news and it's all pretty much on one
[ __ ] subject well a couple but one
subject vladimir putin and the russian
army have invaded ukraine in a hot war
not just not just marching in troops
they have helicopters they have missiles
they have rockets um it seems that
ukraine is pushing back it looks like
the ukrainian prison is asking uh the
citizens of ukraine to stand and fight
so um it doesn't appear that nato has uh
gave any um troops designated now
they're they're waiting and ready um of
course because we actually have a leader
who is willing to
not just acknowledge nato but
participate in the security of nato
and for for democracy not just here but
around the world the the the cheeto dust
mobster the [ __ ] former guy that
[ __ ] traitor he does not he did not
like article five if you remember i'm
just trying to find footage of this
earlier about him knocking article five
in nato that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
he would say [ __ ] like oh well what does
it do us any good they're over there and
we're over here you [ __ ] idiot
he doesn't understand democracy that's
the [ __ ] problem that we had with
that [ __ ] the whole time
he doesn't understand the fundamentals
of democracy he only understands the
transactions that make him rich
personally he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
anything else literally he didn't give a
[ __ ] about his kids his wife he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he doesn't care about the
people around him he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about the people who protect him he
doesn't give two [ __ ] shits if those
people aren't giving him money where he
can make a transaction criminal or not
he isn't interested
that's why he wasn't interested in nato
he couldn't make any criminal
transaction that would benefit himself
so why would he be interested in [ __ ]
nato or article 5 for that matter uh we
have seen article 4 is apparently
instituted not this morning rather
article 5 gets instituted or not it's a
little it's a step a little further than
article 4. article 4 just basically says
that nato is gonna have an official
meeting to plan out what the [ __ ]
gonna happen here article five actually
make sure
that countries can protect themselves
and their borders
and and if they border ukraine they're
gonna protect that border of ukraine
especially if russia's going to push
into that border
now
if you think that vladimir putin
wouldn't have a chance to keep going
past ukraine he absolutely would hitler
did everyone else did that's what they
want that's what tyrants want that's
what dictators want that's what
authoritarians want that's what they
want especially unprovoked that's what
they want
but they like they like to show that
they're provoked so they can go back and
sell the [ __ ] war to their citizens
so
let's let's get to the timeline here let
me make this a little bigger
um because again i've got a lot of video
i want to show you uh today and there's
a lot there's a lot of stuff i retweeted
i'd like to show you as well patriot
take said this one uh but herschel
walker and ted cruz um
sitting underneath the painting of the
cheeto dust mobster here
obviously
an inflated ego of a picture
but they're just chucking it up having a
good old time when donald trump's trying
to get him to suck his little cheeto
here you see this and that come come
come suck my little cheeto dust
penis come suck me and now what this
says this doesn't say power
who says power in a [ __ ] tennis vest
or a country it looks like he's at a
country club
you know raping [ __ ] women or
something i mean it's not far off from
that [ __ ] [ __ ] him [ __ ] him i'm
i'm really [ __ ] pissed this morning i
don't know if you noticed this i'm not
only pissed about the [ __ ] war in
ukraine i am [ __ ] absolutely [ __ ]
infuriated that that [ __ ] traitor
stood in front of a microphone and said
what he said last night and those
[ __ ] cheered him clapped at him
while a few the rest of them were
shoveling food down their [ __ ]
gullets them fat [ __ ]
but you see ted cruz here
just yucking it up with hershel walker
and god god knows how you can even
continue and continue on a conversation
with herschel walker have you heard this
guy talk about [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is he
talking about
little too many hits to the head i guess
this guy's a bonehead [ __ ] bonehead
and here's ted cruz
also bone-headed central
trying to carry on a conversation with
hershel walker he's distracted by donald
trump's crotch in the background get the
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
john says where's biden
not hiding in a bunker
now the media got this all wrong
surprise surprise
they've been scoffing and mocking the
administration
for for [ __ ] weeks ah putin's not
gonna invade putin's not gonna evade
they said no he's gonna invade he's
gonna invade he's gonna invade
still nothing
reuters is reporting uh ukraine uh
zielinski's the ukraine's president
zielinski calls on citizens to fight
promises weapons so he's promising
weaponry to fight
i have not read this article
so i'm not going to speak on the details
yet maybe we'll find some
some info on it uh politics girl lee
mcgowan she reposted her podcast here
and this episode talks about the rise of
autocracy
um i've listened to this episode it's a
very good episode and it explains it
very well why autocracy is the enemy of
democracy which means
which means
it's a threat to us it's a threat to us
and our collective
our collective is more important than
their singular okay
got it thank you lee for reposting that
um you can probably go to her youtube
channel or mine as touch youtube channel
to find
the video of that um and she might have
it in the thread here
uh that's pod link here it is right here
we'll retweet this as well here's the
youtube video that she's got
so thank you lee for reposting that that
is a great episode by the way
um that i've listened to that episode a
very good episode okay let's go back
here
uh gabe posted earlier at least joe
biden isn't eating or flushing documents
down the toilet right now can't say the
same for the former guy and there's no
telling what that [ __ ] would be
flushing down the toilet
probably is probably his secret notes
that the translator had for ukraine uh
aaron earlier post cpac starts today in
that
cpac starts the same day
the same day as their their god
their jesus vladimir putin i mean they
kind of moved on from trump don't you
think
i mean i think so maybe that's why
trump's [ __ ] you know giving vladimir
putin a [ __ ] so hard
really [ __ ] i mean he's got it all
the way in
just because just because
maybe he's he's scared he's gonna lose
the [ __ ] spotlight here
i mean they're really you know
sycophanting
now of course today you know they've
kind of tucked out and run a little bit
now that putin's bombing innocent people
that doesn't i mean that what do they
give a [ __ ] though really what do they
care they put [ __ ] innocent people in
[ __ ] cages children journaling cages
they want to [ __ ] lock up parents and
children of of kids who who have
uh an identity thought
what their gender identity is just the
thought just the thought of having it
and seeking counseling well [ __ ] let's
lock them up
you don't think gas chambers are the
next situation that they want these are
fascist that's why they love putin
that's why they love him so i said about
cpac starting to say today i said here
or in russia where is it where is cpac
starting you know maybe there's a live
feed right onto
russian state tv you damn well better
bet you damn well better bet as vladimir
putin is [ __ ] bombing and killing
innocent
citizens women children
in ukraine those [ __ ] are gonna
get on stage and talk about how strong
he is how great of a leader he is and
the reason why is because vladimir putin
is a murderous dictator he murders
anyone who stands in his way
he murders he'll murder and kill and
dissidents he'll murder and kill
journalists who who will report the
truth he'll murder and kill gays
transgender people anyone anyone he
doesn't like he'll murder them what's
the difference when you're a tyrant when
you're a dictator and you have
totalitarian rule of your country why do
you think they kill people because they
can get away with it no one questions
them
that's what makes them a [ __ ] tyrant
dummies
so i'm sure i'm sure we'll see enough
putin fellatio of cpac this weekend
as he's bombing and killing innocent
women and children in ukraine
we will see it foe show okay so here's
some of the first video um
this is the people of ukraine are
rallying
uh in central russia to protest war um
there's a few images on this thread that
we'll probably go up and look at as well
but this is um this is them protesting
uh you see russian police here trying to
arrest people one by one very quietly to
try to defend the crowd they just don't
want this crowd to grow out of hand and
the idea to grow out of hand that
democracy is a good thing
that fighting for democracy is a good
thing and fighting against
totalitarianism and authoritarianism is
a good thing
when the majority of ideology gets the
gets the way to govern
then we can have liberty
because the only way to deliver a
liberty to people whether it's in this
country or other countries is through
freedoms and rights
now it's not always perfect democracy's
not perfect for crying out loud that's
how they get these [ __ ] people to
believe in author authoritarianism
this christo fascist [ __ ] that we have
in this country right now that they
[ __ ] sycophant on
this q anon trump cult [ __ ]
it's because one guy can fix it
well [ __ ] i can't fix it you can't fix
it democracy can't fix it so what's the
alternative one guy fixing it
one old white nut sack fixing it well i
mean you know paint it up as a cheeto
dust nut sack but you know all the same
here we go here's here is
here is the video
again this is in central russia
you see the police running after people
uh coming after people
the protesting is very peaceful no one's
fighting no one's burning anything
they're chanting
typical for a peaceful protest
again i don't speak a foreign language
so i'm not sure exactly what they're
chanting
but i'm sure it's no war anti-war
something of that nature
and you see in this video uh police
officers and law enforcement officers
thugs
authoritarian thugs
lurking around in this in this crowd
i'm just walking around trying to
probably find
the highest lieutenant or leader of this
situation and removing them you see this
police officer right here here he is
walking over up grabs this person here
walks away
and you see all these people moving in
with their cell phones to take
recordings of it
the situation is real
uh and it's happening
so there's that video uh let's go um
maybe we'll go down or up to see if we
can find here um
here's some more absolutely shocking
footage of russian warplanes of firing
missiles into residential area um so
they're not they're not just bombing
strategic sites
um they're trying to scare the ukrainian
people and to think that there's gonna
be this huge hot war that there's no way
they can win they must give up watch
you want reality
you want to know what authoritarian
looks like you want to know what fascism
looks like you know what i want you know
what it looks like if the gqp takes back
the house they take back the senate they
love [ __ ] putin they [ __ ] love him
this is what they want
this is what they want for our country
got it
don't look away
uh more footage uh let's see thousands
outside in georgia to protest against
kremlin's invasion uh here's more
protest in georgia
the country of georgia
look at these people
standing for democracy
does it matter which
to me it doesn't matter which
it doesn't make any difference the
fundamentals and the principle of
democracy is what we should stand for
uh mj here says um i just want to bring
this up biden remarks have been pushed
back
to 1 30 eastern today
which will be when we're on the air so i
will try if i can to bring those remarks
up thank you mj for giving that update
there i will try to make sure let's
have this on cue here so i have it that
way we can
uh play those remarks as he says them
yeah looks like 12 30 eastern
is um
which is 1 30 my time
um i i don't know if it'll be on air or
not um was it was it 12 30 eastern is
what they're pushing at two or is that
what it was because 12 30 eastern that
is uh that is about right now
um
are they pushing in another hour
okay let's go back push back okay thank
you very much mj thank you for keeping
us up to date i need to put you guys on
like a news desk or something
[Laughter]
for keeping me up to date in the chat
and that's that's where you guys need to
be he's in like a newsroom or something
you know like hey this is happening here
this is happening here uh that way we
can all stay
stay attention to this that's very
important um here's some more video uh
it says ukraine russian invasion forces
are moving through the regional capital
of uh sunny i think it is uh meaning
that the city is probably fallen
so here is um
here is the moving you can see the
convoy here of the russian forces
moving through the city
now the reports were this morning that
russia wasn't really trying to have a
lot of heart attack hot attacks in urban
areas
and the reason why is because if they do
they know they would be crushed fast
they're going to try to take these urban
are these urban areas and ukraine um
with this little little hot force as
they can
and they're going to try to scare the
people into letting them have the urban
areas
hundreds of people ukraine hundreds of
people also marching against war
western russia tonight uh i think the i
think thomas here is saying this is uh
western russia
you wanna you wanna know you don't wanna
know
about what solving problems of humanity
looks like
this is what it looks like
this is what it looks like people
marching for the right reason for
democracy not for autocracy
for democracy for the freedom and the
rights of other people because the
freedom to er oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty and we
strive not not just here
canada all around the world for liberty
got it liberty is the key word liberty
is what will deliver us equality and
equity it really will now it's not
perfect
we've been doing this experiment for
hundreds of years
and it and it was
it was set up on imperfect
but we must continue we must continue
this experiment that's what they don't
want because they know the longer this
experiment goes on the less they're
their their extinction of power is
imminent
uh here's here's the ukraine uh looks
like the russian invasion forces
suffered some substantial losses as they
entered the city so here is the entrance
of the city we just saw
um and this is video of uh looks like
the russian forces
can you imagine driving through your
town
can you imagine just just for a second
imagine the town you live in americans
out there listening close your [ __ ]
eyes close your eyes
imagine the town
that you live in
and you're driving home
and you see
what is
the fascist
who have tried to enter cities to take
the cities
from democratically elected city
councils from democratically elected
county commissions
from state governments
you think i'm [ __ ] kidding
i'm telling you this is what they want
not just there they want it all around
the world the reason why they're backing
vladimir putin isn't because he's a
tough guy vladimir putin is a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
tyrants are
they're they're backing vladimir putin
because they're authoritarians
they're fascists
they want totalitarianism they love this
christian christian fascist [ __ ]
where one person decides
one dictator one king and the [ __ ]
the circle jerk
is that one of them will be that
eventually
well i'll be that one time and then
you'll be that
you'll get to be a dictator then i'll
get to be the dictator
but they love when someone will [ __ ]
oppress the rights of other people is to
give the right people liberty
you follow that
they love authoritarians oppressing the
rights of other people so that way
liberty is delivered to only the people
they want
imagine your town
the sidewalks
the doctor's office the shopping malls
littered with war
imagine
the only the best weapon you have
against this in our country is our
democracy
ukraine ukraine i believe
will win this out democracy tends to win
because democracy is with the people
democracy
wins
not not totalitarianism
good luck vladimir putin
trash
uh looks like um
let's go up here in this thread
it's a lot of video uh we'll go back to
um
i will go back to some more video here
in a minute uh it says insane video
reportedly shows russia's invasion
forces trying to cross
the river uh the
dap near i don't know i i don't speak
russian or ukrainian so it's hard for me
to pronounce some of these words i'm not
good at reading anyways have you noticed
that i [ __ ] suck at reading
you guys have surely have [ __ ]
noticed this [ __ ]
i mean i'm good at talking i can talk
all day long for hours and hours and
hours i [ __ ] suck at reading
especially reading out loud it's one of
my biggest fears actually like i get
anxiety and here i am on a microphone
reading to you people out loud
oh jesus
and talk about insanity uh so let's
let's watch this
looks like um
fighter warplanes
flying over the river
to try to support them crossing
[Music]
and again i'm sure there's a lot of
confusion on the ground there from the
citizens and that's probably why the
president of ukraine president zielinski
has asked the citizens to stand and
fight and he'll give them weapons
because at this point these people are
just trying to live their lives
imagine not being able to go to work is
like oh what's wrong world war three
harry can't come in today
[Music]
okay and so there is uh again warplanes
fighting over to support to support the
advance
russian tanks moving through uh a burn
in a uh the sumnee region
30 kilometers
from the russian border let's see um
let's watch these tanks moving through
this town this is important do not look
away
again
again look there's apartment buildings
there's churches
imagine imagine in your town
imagine i know i know they exist i know
there's a road in your town that you
live in that that looks very similar to
this image that's on the screen
and why why would i say why would i say
oh well that's in ukraine why are you
saying it's gonna happen here this is
what that that [ __ ] stupid ass
freedom dc convoy whatever the [ __ ] that
is the [ __ ] in ottawa the anti-mass the
anti-back stuff all the goddamn school
board [ __ ] all that all of it is in aim
of this
they don't want our ideology to exist
they don't want
democracy
and they will say anything
absolutely [ __ ] anything to convince
people
of that measure
absolutely anything even acting like
they're using freedom and democracy as
their excuse to have totalitarianism
look at the picture
this is your town in this country
jesus christ they stood in you've seen
the video of the [ __ ] standing
in front of charlie kirk at one of his
goddamn events saying when do we get to
kill him
when do we just get to kill him because
they don't have our political opinion
you don't think it can happen here
don't use your power of the ballot don't
use your power in democracy and find out
vladimir putin isn't just fighting a war
on the ukrainian border
vladimir putin is fighting all
democracies around the world
and he's trying to send a signal
to all the people who want to fight
democracies around the world
because they would rather have a
murderous dictator in charge
because they think it will benefit
people who look and are them
fascist at best
authoritarian at the worst
this is your town
in this country that look like that
i've driven two towns in this country
that look almost identical to this
the buildings
the apartments
[Applause]
if it can happen there it'll happen here
ukraine small-scale protest have erupted
in russia
here's another russian um
uh
it says
several dozen people chanting no no to
war
so let's listen
[Music]
[Applause]
more more democracy is spreading
this is good signs
um here is a russian strike on a town in
ukr ukraine
just south of kiev
the invasion forces is launching attacks
all around the capital so they haven't
invaded the capital they're trying to
scare the people in the capital before
they walk in
and here's here's some of the attacks
uh here's some more um
reported fire
from russian invaded forces
again don't look away
don't look away
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is what war looks like
here's another picture
of a helicopter attack
uh here's a picture of more russian
forces that had losses
in ukraine
some more imagery here
here's one near kiev
where low fighting fighters are
are having
[Music]
what what appears to be um uh
plane battles uh
air air battles
[Music]
so the ukrainian and the allied forces
are fighting back i don't think nato has
entered the chat yet um here we go we
got gabe here sorry gabe how long you
been waiting man
oh no not long at all okay
have you have you seen some of this
imagery coming out of ukraine uh i've
seen some of the stuff i also just read
that uh the russians had taken over
chernobyl okay um which so they've taken
the town of chernobyl yeah yeah like the
plant and a lot of people think it's
crazy but from what i understand it's
the shortest distance between uh
to to kiev so
so because their goal is to get to kiev
and apparently they are striking um
around kiev not in kiev specifically but
around it you know probably to
put put people in hysteria there that
that it's going to be taken so you
better go peacefully exactly i think
that's why the president of ukraine has
said fight fight i'll give you weapons
basically i mean it's also pretty crazy
like just to put into perspective too
like you know putin is willing to send
forces through an area that has
radiation
like contaminated with radiation
uh right well i'm sure that they you
know like doesn't care obviously about
uh
uh
you know the well-being of the people
you know the soldiers of russia or
russians he just cares that he's able to
get hold of that
and also then through
uh to to kim yeah so um um
let's see
let's play this video here this
helicopter attack and then uh mj here
says she sent me a
a tweet um about the radiation so let's
watch this first
[Music]
so it so it seems that they started
obviously in the outside rural areas
because they didn't want to just uh bomb
uh urban areas i i think i think
vladimir putin as a as
a piece of [ __ ] as he is that's not a
that's not a bad strategy because if
they were to um
to go to urban areas immediately it
would almost um they would have to
[ __ ] his army very quickly so his
longevity here probably relies on that
strategy um because longevity is what
he's looking for here not a win
because i i don't think i don't think
he's going to win this
as we go through here so um the key of
independent russian forces seized
control
uh the chernobyl
uh nuclear power plant that's what you
were just talking about correct right
the condition of the former chernobyl
nuclear power plant on confinement and
nuclear waste storage facilities is
unknown
so this is a advisor to the head of the
president's office i would imagine the
president here is uh zielinski not our
president there
yeah
because this is coming out of the kiev
independent um so uh thanks thanks um
mj for giving us that our uh that piece
of news i was telling them before we
need to have some of these
they're like our news desk here when
you're on air and they're looking for um
some of these things as it's happening
which uh the news is going to move very
fast in in the next couple days of
course we were going to play the
interview about the um the ottawa convoy
data dump but we decided to take this uh
today instead just because this is fast
moving news this is very important to
democracy not that the other stuff is
not important to democracy and has
nothing to do with russia because i
think when we do end up playing that
interview a lot of people will see that
it's not just the ukrainian border that
vladimir putin is trying to infiltrate
he's trying to infiltrate democracy all
around the world and actually no doubt
with democracy right is there anything
else that you've seen this morning so
far that you'd like to show um
something or that you want to talk about
um before no i just been scanning
through and seeing you know following
school i mean it's crazy because you
know i went to bed last night
uh
what time probably around 1 30
pacific time a.m
and you know
it was
within a couple hours before that not
too long before that that
uh
the invasion had started right uh or i
guess it was a few hours before that um
but the invasion had started and
you know the i think the craziest thing
to think about is that ukrainians and
also russians they went to sleep
they were sleeping
you know uh
to the idea thinking that there was
gonna be war right and then woke up to
this potential of world war three right
like i know people are like oh lord dude
don't be so dramatic but it's like
this is
right what type of [ __ ] that hitler did
to take over that's right that's right
this isn't
because um a lot of people talk about
article four because they invoked
article four i forget that was it um who
was it that invoked article four this
morning i don't want to get it wrong it
was a belarus um they invoked article
four because they're bored and it's not
belarus it's another country that
borders belarus the reason why is
because uh russian forces are right on
that border belarus and that's why maybe
it was belarus i don't know it's it's
very fast moving um but i think
maybe it's possible i went i went to
look up the difference between article 4
and article 5. of course everyone
remembers news about article 5. this is
this is things that most people don't
really realize
but when trump decided he would not
support and back article 5. article 5
gives the nato allied forces the ability
to give assistance to other countries in
the way of troops
right so when you're talking about when
you're talking about an alliance right
it can be an alliance where you're like
no we're on your side yeah we're on your
side we'll have our troops you know uh
you know assisting uh training that sort
of thing and we'll get into the war this
is completely different with this
article vibe because the last time
article 5 was instituted i believe was
on september 12th or september 13th of
2001
but article 4 is a step down from that
not the actual um the the guarantee of
troops as it were if i guess if there's
a simple way to phrase article 5 right
it's the it's the reassurance of troops
but the reason why trump was so pissed
off
um when he was the president about
article five is he would say things like
what does it matter we're over here
there over there that's what he would
say yeah well the problem is is that
democracy and authoritarian can be
anywhere right it doesn't mean and and
and russia and putin it doesn't matter
if democracies here are democracies
wherever it's at putin can attack it in
today's world
in in
1950s 1960s 1970s 1980s uh soviet russia
and even into the 90s even after you
know and what we're dealing with now
with the cage with what was the kgb
that
that there is the reason why we have
article [ __ ] five
right it's because we have to protect
from these authoritarian figures he
doesn't understand that he doesn't
understand that back then you couldn't
attack democracies like you can attack
them today right right i think that's
the big debate that we're gonna have to
have not just here but all around the
world about what social media is and
what it isn't because it's with us we
can't get rid of it we're not gonna get
rid of social media no way no [ __ ]
way so yeah i mean look at you look at
social media and now you know i just saw
lauren beaubert you know and mike
huckabee and all these people who are
saying that well i i didn't know i don't
know what mike huckabee's position was
on this situation before today but today
he was like this is what we're afraid of
these comedies above all this [ __ ] right
and it's like oh well you also put the
guy in office that supported this right
this communist right comment right and
then lauren bobert was like i hope
everyone is more
worried uh about putin than their
pronouns which
uh wasn't she also part of the group
that was supporting putin
well i mean so so i think i i believe
that that there's going to be a little
tuck tail and run here one of the
reasons why is we have cpac right
and and and i believe it is going to be
very unpopular in this country to watch
leaders in our country support our enemy
in this fight regardless who the [ __ ]
the president is rather it's [ __ ]
biden or anyone else i think i think a
lot of people especially hawks
who tend to be sometimes tend to be
conservatives
these hawks are not going to put up with
and i'm not just talking about the
politician the elected people i'm
talking about the voters these hawks are
not going to be very receptive to the
republican party not just backing putin
as a strong dude and he's tougher than
biden and let's go brandon type [ __ ]
yeah we're talking real [ __ ] he is
bombing and killing innocent [ __ ]
people for no reason other than his own
power right
there's
ukraine has not threatened russia
right yeah i mean it's the assumption uh
it's like the assumption of privilege
you know the expectation that
that you know that's ours you know it's
part of our it's part of our culture
it's part of our you know land before
this you know it's it sounds familiar
sounds familiar maybe that's why putin
and hitler are trending together
but i look at this and i'm just like
there is so much you know i i tweeted
about it last night which i think you
might have shared which was the
you know let me get this straight right
now
they didn't want biden involved in any
way shape or form they said bad in don't
you know they're like
he's stupid he's stupid for getting
involved and the reason why is because
the administration says no we have to
get involved because there's going to be
a hot war and they're like no there's
not right right
but i look at this and it reminds me of
like
like kids when they rile something up
right you know whether literally riles
someone up or they they like
they they do something um where
they don't think it's actually gonna
happen right so in this moment you've
got republicans or gqp or conservatives
or whatever they're riling it up to be
like biden so incompetent he shouldn't
do this he'll never be able to get us
out of something
building up this rhetoric of like poking
the bear
and now
the bear decided to
spin around and take a bite right and
now these people are going well no no i
didn't mean it i didn't mean it it was
just i was i was just messing around i
was just i i i wasn't being serious like
there's no reason for you to take me
seriously i was just kidding i didn't
actually think that you're gonna do
something
and that's what's happening right now is
you see them like rile this pro putin
narrative up what's wrong with putin
putin never did this putin never did
that blah blah blah boom putin comes in
at night invades ukraine starts killing
innocent civilians starts going through
taking over chernobyl to get to give
like
what is ukraine done they didn't take
they didn't take a move against uh
russia we never took a move against
russia putin did this as a reaction or
you know reactive or whatever you want
to call it move
to be ahead of the the game right he
wanted to make a move so he was in
charge he was in power
and now you have all these people from
the gqp and republican party who say oh
well no we didn't actually think
anything was going to happen because now
the [ __ ] has hit the fan and this guy is
killing innocent people so now
what what are they supporting are they
supporting a guy
who is killing us some people that
had no no fight taken against him to
start it off
that's the big problem and i think
that's where a lot of people are gonna
like try to delete tweets and move back
and say they weren't involved and they
never said anything they weren't
supporting putin and all this [ __ ]
meanwhile they're like did you did you
see did you see tucker carlson did you
see donald trump last night in front of
a microphone right they didn't they
didn't back down at all they were full
throated balls deep baby yeah i didn't
see tucker last time i saw him the night
before but right that's that yeah right
right
now in that clip right he's just like oh
would poot never do this pooh's not a
bad guy he would never do this bad stuff
meanwhile he wants he wants peace he
wants right meanwhile he's like you know
has he ever done this to you has he ever
done this to you
while also ignoring like has he ever
poisoned a journalist you know has he
ever done like these are all things that
putin is dissidents gay people
transgender people totally just decided
to not include those things instead go
to the
has putin eating a dog does he have dogs
you know what you know what's funny
about what we're just talking about is
that the same the same week that we have
vladimir putin this
dictorial the murderous tyrant this vile
piece of [ __ ] who who honestly is
marching down the road of a tyrant i
mean honestly i i figured if if putin
weren't to invade ukraine he probably
had at least 10 years left to rule
russia um my my guess is is that putin
has reduced his time to rule russia um
probably by half at least if not more
than that and he'll probably end up
again in a bunker in a hole or at the
end of a rope that's how these things
end that's just how this [ __ ] ends
to be honest you can't it doesn't go any
other way with these tyrants because
democracy and the people in this in this
world now that they've seen democracy
and they have democracy we just don't
tolerate the intolerant and i can't
believe in that same [ __ ] week we
have the state of [ __ ] florida in the
state of texas wanting to pass bills to
jail parents who have children who who
have a an idea of an uh their gender
identity they question it they question
it simple counseling that they would
seek to manage those ideas and that
thought and that identity crisis that
that person that [ __ ] human being the
child may have
vladimir putin would murder them yep
you got it vladimir putin would [ __ ]
murder them and here they are on tv
what's wrong what's wrong with with
these parents and he's transgender let's
shoot to a break hey vladimir putin's
such a great guy
do you see how the slow march
yeah i mean it's completely on brand
it's in the same message uh category of
against these people you know one is
obviously a person who's going to take a
life or death
uh
spin on that uh that belief and the
other one is moving in that direction
where you know illegal move these people
away destroy a society by
by excluding a group of people that oh
by little by little right because
they're not one or zero they're not
binary they're not male to female this
child doesn't feel right in their own
body and says and it's that also march
right and also march also i would you
know i've said this before it's like
a person who is able to say you know
what i don't feel comfortable my own
body and i would like to transition into
one or the other
has an incredible amount of bravery and
courage and respect
to do that
and and go forward because
they
were able to stand up for themselves and
say i don't feel right right now
and i want to feel
more comfortable and i want to feel
safer and i want to feel more like
myself because i don't
right and none of these people that push
them away and say like you're not real
or you're not this or whatever like
those people are weak those people speak
out of like projection for fear of their
own you know whether it's themselves who
are not comfortable in their own body or
because they don't like what's different
than them or they don't like because
this person was strong or confident
enough to take up that change right
and these people just want them to be
as miserable as them
if you're better off than me whether
it's how you feel mentally emotionally
physically financially whatever
that can't happen
you can't be off you can't uh you can't
be better than me you you can't be be be
in a better position than i
and if you are then i gotta knock you
down
and i gotta bring you down to my level
and i gotta bring you down below me so
that you know that i'm in power and i
rule and i have the upper hand here and
that [ __ ]
is disgusting and vile and it's the same
[ __ ] that's happening when you look at
these people who try to rule over
different countries putin a prime
example you're different you're not like
me uh done you're not this
supreme race uh done like these are the
type of people that you'll slowly find
who take power and the gqp is on that
rise that's right where they're trying
to enter the handmaid's that's what they
want here exactly
they would love they would love to watch
fascist tanks roll through democratic
elected cities
to take those cities
we had we had people at charlie kirk's
speaking events saying out loud into a
microphone when can we start killing
them right asking charlie kirk as if he
has some sort of power to dictate when
you can start killing them and that's
the key that's the [ __ ] key it's
always them it's always the other it's
all right to strip away all humanity
from what is your enemy that way your
enemy can be easily disposed of um
speaking of of
inhumane [ __ ] this is this is a
video from 2019 october i believe um
this is the former president the [ __ ]
traitor he is here's him talking about
nato and article five and this is that
slow walk to where we're at right now
with vladimir putin doing what he's
doing
more difficult in future um
times of need to develop alliances no it
won't be uh it won't be at all alliances
are very easy but you know our alliance
alliances are very easy yeah they're
easy for you because you inherited them
and you tried to destroy them right
america has been working for these
alliances not for a couple [ __ ]
months
this is the [ __ ] boneheaded [ __ ] that
these [ __ ] authoritarians these
goddamn fascists in this country don't
understand about democracy they don't
get it they won't get it and they'll
continue not to get it and our only way
is for pro-democracy people to push back
so that we can have our democracy and
they'll just live in it
that's what we have to get to have taken
advantage of us if you look at how much
money we spend on nato and how much
money is the thing
there are poor really a much bigger
beneficiary than we are okay you know
this they're there and we're here we're
many miles away again he doesn't
understand the beneficiary part he
doesn't understand why it's so important
to have democracy in the places where we
can have democracy because without it
you have vladimir putin going and taking
countries that aren't theirs exactly
it's just it's [ __ ] sickening um
let's go back to um the timeline here
i was also just sent a message uh or or
we were tagged in a message that says
the kremlin website as well as most
russian government websites are down
so
you know i think there's a a few things
to take from this is this is this the
one from uh president biden that no this
is uh chris joe grosef
okay uh let me see if i can uh sure if
you got if you got the link send it to
me i'll pull it up on this you were
tagged in it
uh you know i got i've got a lot of
[ __ ] notifications yeah here let me
i will i have one that robin sent of um
22 minutes ago and i think the president
is going to speak in about 25 minutes i
believe so um if we if we are still on
the air and he speaks we will probably
pull uh the president in um to see what
he has to say um he did tweet this robin
sent this so let me let me pull up what
you have and then i'll pull up the um
the president's uh comments here um
so this is um
um
the kremlin the kremlin website uh let's
see there you go as well as russian
government websites are down do you
think that's a signal that the united
states has taken action
uh you know i i don't know i i look at
that in either there's two ways you can
interpret this because because you're
that you're the webb tech expert right i
mean so
the the two interpretations here is
either one there's a coordinated effort
to take down
um
these things from an outside party
right two
it is an effort from
within
putin's
like a false flag type thing not
necessarily false flag but if you take
down the website and all communication
then um
you you prevent now i don't know why
they would do it for russian website or
government websites but basically you
know this is again like what we talked
about in the interview if you're able to
dismantle like the way to dismantle
society it because we so heavily depend
on the internet is to take down certain
services or communication channels so if
you're able to do that you know
especially if there's a group of people
within russia that have a resistance
against what's happening they don't want
some sort of coordination to happen so
they take it down preemptively now
there's also the other effort which you
could say was done by a third party and
they took it down as a as an attack
against
uh the kremlin attack against russia now
yet to be seen what it is but those are
two possibilities of what it could be
um probably more the
the coordinated effort than the latter
but who knows you know i mean it i think
it's anyone's game in terms of this
because putin could shut off
communication and just say
what you hear are the only the only
things you're going to hear from us is
what we want you to hear
and uh and then when everything is all
settled and done and we've taken over
certain areas then we'll let you know
what happened right right uh because
again they're you know they're in russia
and that's ukraine so you know these
russians aren't in ukraine to actually
see what's going on they're only going
to hear
through
uh from
any sort of russian intelligence or uh
agency that decides that what they want
to pick and choose what's heard so i'm
not exactly sure why they would take
down the government website right now um
but so i think it's more of a
coordinated effort an attack against
them from a third party than it is them
actually preemptively taking it down
just to
uh
well here's the president's account here
he says uh this morning i met with my g7
counterparts to discuss president
putin's unjustified attack to ukraine oh
thanks for pulling it up there um and we
agreed to move forward on devastating
packages of sanctions and other economic
measures to hold russia into account we
stand with the brave people of ukraine
so um here he is saying a devastating
package of sanctions and economic
measures um that doesn't clearly
indicate that there were that the
internet being down would be a
possibility of the g7 counterparts uh
moving in on on quote unquote uh what
would be repercussions of vladimir
putin's unjustified actions here um and
his attack on ukraine so
um now rather you know like you're
saying rather it's an internal strategy
because it's going to be it's this is
going to be fast moving um you know i i
give putin maybe two or three years here
but i may be way off base right we may
be way way out
and ann actually says i just sent you
the link for it but she says pushkin
square in russia is full of protesters
and uh so i just sent you that if you
want to play it uh is that the link you
just sent yeah okay let's uh let's see
this here
uh is it from venman
yes okay um so um alexander venman as
you know from the the first impeachment
trial about the
quid pro quo in ukraine
pushkin square maybe less than a
thousand meters from red square in the
kremlin is the site of a significant
protest these people know the risk of
challenging the regime they're on the
streets in spite of major personal costs
probably their lives at this point um
which um yeah i i think we're going to
see more and more of this around the
world as as people wake up to what the
[ __ ] is happening all over the place
right for convoy [ __ ] this anti-back
[ __ ] this uh this nonsense it's not what
you think it is that's not the peaceful
protest they're fighting to to undermine
democracy
this is democracy right here
i believe they're chanting uh no no two
war because we watched a video earlier
and they were chanting the same thing
and they translated it into no to war
i wonder how recent this video is um he
posted this at about about 30 minutes
ago so i wonder how old this video is
when he posted it um but either way
either way people in russia itself
are fighting back against um what putin
is doing uh to ukraine so let me let me
retweet this and give credit here uh to
alexander vinman
um thank you for the for posting the
video um
let's see what else do we have on the
docket here um i had uh let's see let me
find let's pull
while i'm searching here let me find um
i had a couple other things bookmarked
uh one of the things is um speaking of
the president united states
here he is
um and it looks like it is
uh july 14th of last year when he's
talking at nato and he's talking about
article 5 as we were just talking about
let's go to that real quick
seeking to drive a wedge in our
transatlantic solidarity
we're seeing an increase in malicious
cyber activity
but our alliance is a strong foundation
on which we can our collective security
and our shared prosperity can continue
to be built
and i made a point to make clear that
the u.s commitment to article 5 the nato
treaty
is rock solid and unshakable
it's a sacred commitment
nato
nato stands together
that's how we've met every other threat
in the past
it's our greatest strength
as we meet our challenges of the future
and our sorry about the audio being so
low but
you kind of get the point here uh of
this post posted by sarah reese jones um
all the way back in 2021 which i am
going to retweet because i think it is
highly relevant um the reason why it's
relevant is because the reason why
the reason why joe biden was standing up
saying this
in june of last year is because of what
is happening today
they they know who putin is putin's not
some kind of mysterious [ __ ] he
tries to be he tries to be he tries to
be some kind of mysterious figure like
he you know you can't catch him type
[ __ ]
they know who the [ __ ] he is they know
what he is and who he is now let's go
back to the trendy trends and the tweety
tweets here and see of course we have
ukraine the
story in chernobyl
looks like it keeps um
ticking up here from the nuclear power
plant as the russian forces move in um
on that uh nato obviously is um trending
it's pretty much all russia today
taiwan is trending um again the the
just about
putin's only way out of this and only
ally in this game a big ally that is is
probably china
now
china is going to be an ally with
anyone who's a murderous dictator in the
first place xi ji ping is definitely not
going to side with democracy here um
that is not going to be a thing um
let's see we have we have some other
things that are that are trending with
some hot takes which i'm not going gonna
even get into that i don't think it's
worth it at this point
uh i guess i don't i'm not sure if the
report came out yet but there was uh on
ali velshi's uh belgium's msnbc show
last night they were reporting that the
new york times said it was reporting u.s
and intel agencies noticed that putin
began moving his troops and weapons to
ukraine the day after trump's failed
january sixth insurrection
so so yeah so well i mean um if anyone's
wondering out there why vladimir putin
wanted trump and didn't want biden and
why what's happening because i've heard
this oh well
biden are uh excuse me this would never
happen if it was under trump yeah never
happened
but the reason why is because putin had
the president united states trying to
take over ukraine for him on the inside
like why would he go to a hot war when
he had a president united states trying
to make sure that that that ukraine
would come back to russia the only the
only difference that i think people need
to realize is that if trump was still
president then
this is what would have happened right
uh we would have had the same outcome
where where putin would go into ukraine
the only difference is the u.s would
support
any of those measures and moves right
that's why you see that [ __ ] on fox news
and oan and all these other places that
are
supporting this narrative of what would
trump do you know right like this is
that's not the standard that you should
hold yourselves to like what would jesus
do what would trump do is the the
opposite thing you ever want to do in
life because what's going to happen is
this guy wants to drive up
any sort of uh of tension and stress
to just you know to obviously better
himself but
what's happening here is this outcome
would have happened under trump the only
difference is it would have been under a
supportive
country as one that says hey we
shouldn't do that this would come under
one when it's like yeah you know what
that's actually theirs and the border
rights and whether you joined nato and
that this and that like no
it would have happened the only
difference is that
uh it would have been under a president
that would have said yeah that's cool
you guys yeah just go take it just just
go around in right like
not not as some sort of like
human rights gatekeeper that says nah
probably shouldn't do that you know like
we we should
that is the opposite of what should
happen here like we're not going to go
to war we're not going to take over
people's uh
countries
um
yeah it's uh you know and everyone's
like oh
no
putin putin like they love this guy and
then now that like i said now that they
[ __ ] poke the bear and he's like
taking up taking us you know a little
bit of a bite
they're like oh you know some people are
gonna double down and maybe triple down
and like be like putin is in the right
here
it's his property ukraine is part of
russia and those people are russians and
they don't have any rights except those
that are decided by putin
and then you're going to have those who
look back and go
uh i got a course correct let me let me
uh right 180 here or let me be like oh
[ __ ] i didn't know the murders dictator
would try to be him right right like i i
i didn't think like i just thought it
was all like fun and games like i
thought we were just like you remember
you remember this story that eric
swalwell he's told us several different
places but i think it was a minus dutch
podcast that he told the story and it
kind of went around but he tells a story
about during the the first impeachment
right that had to do with ukraine he was
one of the floor managers right or was
it the second one i don't remember [ __ ]
they all kind of blend together jesus
christ so um he's taking a piss
in the in the uh senate bathroom right
at the urinal and ted cruz comes up next
to him and taking a piss next to him and
ted cruz looks at eric's wall and says
hey man you're doing a great job out
there
like go buddy like you're doing the
right thing i'm doing my job you're
doing your job it's all pretend and eric
swallow was like what in the [ __ ] are
you this is not pretend this is [ __ ]
real this is not [ __ ] professional
wrestling this is not a game this is
[ __ ] real life [ __ ] this is happening
in front of us it's it's it's disturbing
um yeah it's it's it it is yeah to that
point like it is one of those things
it's like you cannot
you cannot like you know it's great to
find a middle ground to be like hey you
know i still respect you as a person
exactly we're able to debate right but
not when it's like hey man you're
putting on a good show right yeah don't
go too hard because i'm not gonna you
know
we need to show a little tension here
but one of us is gonna have to win so
someone's got to pull the punches you
know gonna have to make you know you
know some fake blood here and some throw
throw your body that way it's like no no
we're we're not coordinating the [ __ ]
like [ __ ] wrestling okay
well i mean i think that again you know
i've said several times that that we're
in the intersection of wrestlemania in
real life
here is some good news so far i know
it's hard to find good news um but there
have been no reports that nuclear
weapons have um have been used in the
unfolding situation in ukraine despite
the fact that putin did threaten
basically he said that if anyone comes
in between me like it
it's like uh like a like a toxic
relationship like coral right like you
have this abusive uh partner and they're
now threatening
the other partner
and anyone else
who gets in the middle of our [ __ ] you
take one step forward and try to defend
them i'm gonna [ __ ] shoot you and i
was like dude what the [ __ ] calm down
man you got anger management issues
right meanwhile we're just talking about
where we're gonna go have dinner it's
like dude we just wanna figure like uh
you know it's like a neighbor or
whatever but
you know uh
you look at it and now he's like listen
if anybody [ __ ] comes in here and
tries to deal with this [ __ ] i'm gonna
nuke your ass and it's like dude what
the [ __ ] like you went from like hey
we'll shoot you pew pew too like we're
gonna [ __ ] blast you and your whole
area and you'll have to deal with
radiation like you want you want you
wanna you want like hiroshima you want
chernobyl you want like all these like
what the [ __ ] is going on
uh
calm down they're [ __ ] crazy don't
nuke people and do not take it to a
[ __ ]
nuke situation that's like going from
let's have a discussion to
back the [ __ ] off we're at an 11 right
now right and it's like right
well
i i i think the good news is that
there's no reports at this point i think
the reason why people were asking this
is because the stuff that's uh unfolding
in chernobyl um where they have these
well so i hope that the reports are true
i hope that these you know this
situation of nuclear weapons is not
actually gonna be one that's taken
forward
and nothing will be done you know for
everyone's
sake but i don't like at this point i
you know putin could say one thing right
and in the background he's doing
something else
uh you know like he's you know moving
troops forward slowly to the border
after january 6 you know threatening
everyone that he's going to take a move
but not take a move and then delay it by
a week and then take a move to go
forward right and go into ukraine
because there was initial reports that
he was supposed to enter ukraine on on
february 16th and now we're eight days
well i guess a week later
he entered ukraine so
right and that's probably because um he
he
made sure that
because he's testing he's testing
democracy and he's testing joe biden the
president united states here because
ultimately the president united states
is the most powerful man in the world
whether it's joe biden it's donald trump
it's barack obama whether it be a woman
they are the most powerful person in the
world because they hold the keys to the
most powerful military not only that the
most powerful alliances in the world
they hold the keys to that and so that
is the that is the key here um heidi
cuda
from radicalized podcast um she was on
our show and she's the co-host with high
fidelity which we had the interview for
that we were going to play today but we
pushed it back because of all this news
um she says here arrest mike flynn this
looks like um
jim stewartson also their co-host um who
was banned from twitter so i guess
that's why heidi's
making sure to get it get it out there
on twitter um
as posted on his sub stack um highlight
here at putin's legitimate security
concerns and legitimate ethnic uh
problems in the ukraine
we have yet to hear from president of
the united states an explanation of the
u.s national security interest
instead we continue to demonize russia
this is from mike flynn
um similar to the fake russia collusion
hysteria which now we know is real
because he's saying it's
i mean when you're saying these things
like this where it's an obvious lie that
the demonizing of russia
russia is not being demonized
yeah he's a [ __ ] murderous dictator
what the [ __ ] i don't know how you can
look at what he's been doing
uh yeah it's like i don't know i don't
know if how you could look at what he
has done and what he just did in the
last 12 hours well and that's probably
the tuck tailing and running right right
right
you know uh um they can they can skate
around the whole he's murdering his
dissidents murdering people he doesn't
like right killing them
they could skate around that because ah
there's obscurity there right there
might be a conspiracy there's a story
it's [ __ ] hard it's [ __ ] hard to
ignore
[ __ ] rockets bombs gunships
helicopters troops tanks it's hard to
ignore that [ __ ] right it's really
[ __ ] hard to ignore that you know
grabbing someone a video of someone
grabbing someone and throwing them in a
van you know you can kind of explain
that away this you cannot explain away
right um this [ __ ] traitor also goes
on to say let's see here he says now no
uh was perpetrated against the trump
administration by elements of the
clinton campaign of course they're
continuing this [ __ ] line their lies
on top of lies on top of lies president
putin calculated this strategic historic
and geographical play and made the
decision to move and he did
all that stated above there will never
be justification for this invasion
or any other form of invasion however
but
but
never forget war results
when diplomacy fails this is this is
this is and this this is what putin
wants he wanted pompeo to parrot his
propaganda he wanted tucker carlson to
parrot his propaganda he wants elected
officials in this country to parrot his
propaganda because people like [ __ ]
mike flynn also parrot his propaganda
because that's what he's saying
what he's saying here is not diplomacy
they're attacking democracy diplomacy
hasn't failed diplomacy didn't fail
vladimir putin was hell-bent on
murdering people with his weapons of war
and he was hell-bent on taking ukraine
rather there was diplomacy or not
because i believe that that vladimir
putin understands one thing democracy is
his enemy he will not last long if
people believe in democracy especially
in his country um so people if people
have a say and the the voice of the
people you know is strong then that is
against what putin wants he doesn't want
anyone to be
uh equal in rights other than himself
and you look at the statement and it's
you know that last but it's like listen
but okay with that being said which is
right right gates should never invade
but right it's like never made but this
is what happens it's like uh no this is
actually a result of what you and trump
did during your right uh your your
but
you know again when someone says oh
don't do this
but with that being said you know it's
like no
no this it it takes everything away from
what you just previously said because
now you're defending the actions of a
dude who is killing people in another
country because he wants that country
right well um i think mj sent that to us
so thank you to mj let me go over to let
me check something here real quick i
just want to see if they have um what
the schedule for
okay they still have it on schedule for
1 30 eastern which is in about
six seven minutes something like that
for the president to speak again if he
does come on i will try to uh go to the
president um and hear what he has to say
i think it's important we normally don't
do like breaking news like that but but
i think today it's uh probably
appropriate to do um there were some
other videos um i wanted to play here
let me go to my timeline i think i
retweeted them just so we play them uh
the one is trump actually speaking uh
last night that [ __ ]
treasonous piece of [ __ ] um and you will
know what i mean yeah i think yeah you
retweeted as well bill chris crystal um
had put it up uh here is the um let's go
to the video here um so this is uh i
don't know what kind of event this is i
i guess this is probably a mar-a-lago
fundraising event for candidates it says
maga and i'm not sure if this is
preempting cpac or whatever this is just
the grift keeps on grifting or what but
yeah i mean it's all the same at this
point it's gonna be hard to hear because
uh this is taken from a cell phone um
and he's speaking into a microphone but
listen to what he says trump said he's
smart i mean he's taken over a country
for two dollars worth of sanctions
he's he's putin smart he's smart it's a
great investment two dollars worth of
sanctions and he gets a whole country
can you believe it
what the [ __ ]
it's ridiculous craziness
that's pretty smart
he's
what's crazy is you look at all these
people and they're just like gobbling up
the their whatever the [ __ ] they're
eating and they're like yeah this is
great we're having a great time or
eating we have this [ __ ] tyrant up
here this [ __ ] trees in his bastard
he's an un-american who's not a patriot
who would sell america for he would sell
america for two dollars worth of
sanctions
that's a [ __ ] great deal hell i would
i would sell this state or that type for
two dollars worth of sanctions why not
that's a great deal
trump would trump would sell anything if
it means he could pay off his uh right
his lenders you know i mean like i mean
you mean the people who yeah exactly the
people who hold debt over his head you
know whatever you could do to uh pay off
those debts whether it's uh through
through not doing something or through
doing something right like through
through uh
through trying to remove any sort of
blockade or barriers of entry for russia
into other areas you know like
anything again anything to pay off the
debtors that's
he's a he's a man that has been bought
it's transaction it's a tran he sees he
sees his ukrainian thing not not as war
he doesn't see it as a fight against
democracy he sees it as a transaction
well i mean you know putin it's a good
deal it's a good investment let's listen
to what else this trader says piece of
land with a lot of people and just
walking right in this would have never
happened ever in a million years would
have never happened and i know him very
well i know
probably almost as well as i know
anybody in this room other than dr
ronnie doc ronnie nursery who is not
drunk
doc ronnie in the back end drunk taking
shots
guys
yeah i i lied about trump's health uh
hey how you guys doing uh he said he was
the most healthiest person in the entire
[ __ ] world what a piece of [ __ ] i
think he said he was the healthiest
president or something like that you
know [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that guy let's
see let's give bill chris crystal credit
here i just sent you something yes you
know waiting on confirmation for this
obviously i don't know if i would trust
uh what's what the russians will say and
admit but
uh it seems to be that uh
maybe well it maybe maybe it will tell a
story though i mean uh it may be true it
may not be true it is what they're
saying though right
so let's uh josh letterman here and if i
can get it to zoom in um ukrainians
ambassador to the us just told us that a
russian platoon from the 74th mobilized
brigade has surrendered to ukrainian
forces so this is gonna we're gonna hear
this happening yeah russian forces are
not ready to invade ukraine right
they're not
vladimir putin is desperate but the
russian forces are not matched to the
equipment and the training that the
ukrainians probably have not only that
is if nato gets involved they definitely
do not have the army to fight the nato
forces
um she says that the russian troops
apparently have been unaware they were
uh
begin uh
were being sent to kill ukrainians
holy [ __ ] no confirmation yet from
russia's military she says that the
russian troops apparently
had been unaware they were sent to kill
ukrainians think about that for a second
yeah think about that for a second
we in this country know exactly why
putin was there
exactly putin there the [ __ ] troops
that were going
didn't even know they were sent to kill
ukrainians and this is [ __ ] important
this is really important and the reason
why it's important is because
russian
forces
have family who live in ukraine yeah
right like they have families it is
connected not just not just by a border
but by people
well it is connected it's it is crazy
well i mean like it's crazy to think
that
you know i don't know what the reason
was given you know for
to say like okay you know when they're
like okay why are we going to ukraine
it's like you're going to ukraine to
peacekeep you know you're going to
ukraine to
stabilize the region from our attacks um
but then they go in there and yeah all
of a sudden you get you know ukrainian
soldiers potentially shooting at you
because you're you're supposed to go in
there and kill people it's like oh [ __ ]
no no it's like i never signed up for
this i had a this is not what i wanted
you know
but i think obviously you're in a
position where you you know you you you
answer to
the the supreme leader uh commander that
is putin and you don't really have a
choice right you go where he says to go
however in terms of what
only higher up individuals know as like
what the mission or what the the
strategy is you know those are those
people and then you've got the lower
runs the pawns that go in the soldiers
who probably have very little aren't
privy to certain information so they go
in with
not knowing they're just like oh we're
just going to go and maintain we're just
going to go in and survey we're just
gonna go in
and and check it out not do anything
right meanwhile it's like no you guys
have to [ __ ] shoot these people it's
like right and then they're like whoa
wait a second then they give up so i'm
gonna go to one more clip before we uh
possibly bring the president on um this
is really weird that we have to go all
the way back to 2016 to the dnc you
remember the dnc where they dumped the
dem the emails on wikileaks about bernie
sanders and hillary clinton and there
was this big um story about how the dnc
had been hacked and the russians had
used wikileaks um to release these
emails this is robbie mook the uh
hillary clinton's campaign manager at
the time and he's being questioned um by
jake tapper here or cnn and it really is
it really is striking to go back and
look at this and understand
that
um even the media back then was like
putin russia come on really
listen to this disturbing to us is that
we uh experts are telling us that uh oh
by the way i do want to preempt this by
saying the email lady knew i just want
to bring him down actors broke into the
dnc
stole these emails and uh other experts
are now saying that they are the
russians are releasing these emails for
the purpose of actually helping donald
trump i don't think it's coincidental
that these emails were released uh on
the eve of our convention here and and
that's disturbing uh and i think we need
to be concerned about that i think we
need to be concerned that we also saw uh
last week at the republican convention
that trump and his allies made changes
to the republican platform uh uh to make
it more pro-russian and and we saw him
talking about how nato shouldn't
intervene to defend necessarily should
intervene to defend our eastern european
allies if they're attacked by russia so
i think when you put all this together
it's a it's a disturbing picture and i
think isn't that funny isn't that i mean
i mean how could robbie mook and
possibly have any idea that putin his
main goal to destroy the idea that nato
is a security for
for eastern and europe and excuse me
western europe and eastern europe and
western democracy how could he have
known
how is it possible that back in 2016
that that it was so important not to
elect trump to undermine nato hmm i
wonder i wonder why i wonder why the
email lady knew this it's because she's
she was ready to be [ __ ] president of
the united states
probably more ready than joe biden it
was ready to be right i mean you look at
him you say like oh what was her
position what was she doing in the
administration oh that makes sense why
she might know certain things yeah
that's why she has experience and would
say oh yeah this is uh very much inside
the wheelhouse of the type of tactics or
strategies that this group would do
right like right and everyone else is
like hey lady
uh emails
right you know it's like okay let's
let's actually focus on what the real
problem is but yeah sure i'll sit
through 11 hours of
uh interview questions but whatever
right right well uh i thought that was
significant this morning when i found
that video of uh robbie mook talking at
the dnc
of why it is so important that we don't
undermine nato and and it could possibly
lead to a murderous dictator trying to
take democratically elected countries um
i am keeping an eye on c-span here um it
looks like they have not gone to the
president yet they're waiting for him i
think um so c-span's doing their normal
thing where they just this uh
last night last night when i went to bed
uh i don't know have you seen war games
war games yeah yeah is it a movie or is
it yeah it's a movie with uh
with uh
matthew broderick
it's the whole
the whole premise is uh where
he's playing a video game
and then he finds out that he actually
is not playing a video game but rather
he has found a back door
uh into a military central like computer
and he starts playing and then he's like
causing
uh world war three essentially
and i went to bed last night and i was
like oh man imagine if
you know obviously that was before it
was like the 80s when it came out it's
like 83 so it was before obviously you
know we had the the
type of communication channels we have
right now right yeah right
or even the four side of it really right
right right yeah but uh you know i look
at that and i was like
that i was thinking about that last time
i was like oh man maybe this is like a
bad dream and it's like someone who like
actually hacked and is playing a game
and it's all just like some
big miscommunication you know some crazy
simulation type thing but obviously it's
not it's just a [ __ ] fascist dictator
who wants to
uh who wants to rule and obviously you
know history
will repeat itself like it always does
and he'll find out that it's not going
to work out no well it tyrants tyrants
again they they generally end up um
in in a bunker or in a hole somewhere
yeah dead dead or alive and they're not
usually by their own hand or someone
else's you know right and usually if
they are pulled out of the hole alive
they are not alive for very much longer
because they end up at the end of a rope
um we've seen this in our modern history
um with some of these tyrants uh rather
it was justified for us to go to war in
some of these countries or not that's
what happens to some of these people
we've seen gaddafi we've seen
saddam hussein yeah you can go back to
hitler you can't
you you can't control for very long when
you're doing that you know now you're
gonna
you may have some fans along the way
but sooner or later you're gonna do
something to piss everyone off and say
okay that was too far you know and then
now the alliance or allies that you had
at one point begin to dwindle
well you're left alone
and that's the thing you get you get
because you get so paranoid right and
you've seen how paranoid it is like he
won't even [ __ ] stand within 60 feet
of someone right so so you get so
paranoid that your circle gets smaller
and smaller and smaller and smaller
right so so as your circle gets smaller
you don't have any way outside that that
little that little circle and the more
you get paranoid the more you you get
delusional right
so the more delusion that happens you
get uncoupled from reality and as you
get uncoupled from reality that's when
reality strikes
it's the thing that i will say is uh
is
it is
something you also see with like uh
like there are stories of um
what's her face from theranos
and like uh travis
from
uber which is like all these people who
are like high profile ceos right they're
like doing something that's you know
illegal and i don't know if it's anxiety
and in in
and pressure and fear of somebody
finding out about it but they there's
this tendency for people of certain uh
hold on up
here come the russians
uh no but i i look at it and i'm like
there's a similarity between like world
leaders who have this much power and
there's a fear of people coming after
them
and also the same type of anxiety and
paranoia that certain uh corporate
leaders have you know whether it's
they've been doing something illegal or
not and they're trying to cover up and
they're afraid that people are going
after them
but you see this similar type of
behavior where they start freaking out
and they think everyone's after them and
they're thinking someone's trying to
steal this and do this and you know
whether it's you know someone trying to
to steal secrets or whatever it is but
like they're
they get delusional and they begin
losing their mind and they're like
paranoid that everyone's out to get them
and
um
you know when especially those people
who are like i i need to have a
close-knit circle like only i can trust
the people in this room and then once
things start leaking i can't trust
anyone and like i i don't believe what
you're gonna tell me and then these
people end up you know
it's uh it's themselves that end up
bringing themselves down you know right
well yeah well i mean exactly you know
it's their it's their untethering from
reality little by little and and putin
definitely is untethered from reality
here um that he thinks he's gonna he's
going to be able to defeat nato
rather it's through
a lot of questioning democracy which i
believe that his questioning of
democracy or getting people to question
democracy is actually going to
strengthen it because i think people
will find that democracy is better than
what the [ __ ] is going on in ukraine
right now right
you have a stark difference that's why
you have these republicans out there
that thought it was some kind of game
eye he's not gonna really do it we'll
just we'll just play this little [ __ ]
you know this little game and let the
media do this thing and we'll get our
all our supporters riled up on social
media it'll be great for fundraising
here we are
so we're still watching a common enemy
if we say again the gqp right now
anything they are pro anything that is
anti-biden that is their that's right
whole message right now own the lib
target exactly they don't care if it's
more people that die from covid if it's
uh you know uh
loses a war like right but you
understand you understand biden losing a
war means
america loses like right yeah so it's
one of those things where it's like oh
i'll you know i'll you know if i die i
take it for the team or whatever the
[ __ ] is right like for the greater
good of of owning [ __ ] libs like it's
you know it's the same mentality it is
so delusional and so
disorienting where you would think like
how can someone think this way but you
have a tunnel vision group of people who
think uh if he fails we win when in
reality if he fails
we all lose
right
and it's not like all of a sudden he's
like oh well if biden loses then it's
like you have you have him or you have
harris or you have someone else from the
administration up through
another uh two years right so
uh you're lose like if he loses we lose
you also keep losing because you have
another democratic person in office
you're not getting trump you're not
getting someone else
well and speaking of president biden
we're still waiting on him i think you
have to jump off here i got to do um
let's go to a break and then we'll come
back maybe uh joe biden will be speaking
uh thanks for joining us gabe thanks for
the time you give us i we all i know the
audience always appreciates your
appreciates your insight it's just a
shame that vladimir putin joined us
yesterday instead of today to break news
but yeah he joined he joined us yeah he
joined us yesterday you booked the
interview and he came you booked the
interview
it's really funny it's really funny how
sometimes like you book these interviews
and you're not there to you know i don't
know when he's going to show up you know
they're on different time zones i just
booked it through a middle guy and then
yep you i never showed i was hoping you
would show up yesterday yesterday i was
busy with work so i didn't have any time
it happens we'll get back to work um
audience stick around uh we'll try to
see if we can catch some of the
president's comments right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headlines
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around for the break
maybe we should have took a break
earlier but me and gabe were on a roll
there
thanks to everyone who
sent us some of those links to get some
of this information out there and into
the podcast we always appreciate you
guys um helping us out and like i said
maybe we should call you the media desk
not the comment section
um you guys do a fantastic job trying to
alert us
never be scared if if if my dms are open
to you they're always open so um and and
forgive me if i if i um don't seem to
get them i do get a lot of dms sometimes
so i try to shuffle through them every
day i try to make sense of them
sometimes uh if you know what i mean but
then so so simmi diems you can also uh
post a link here uh in the comment
section
or you can tag us on any uh post that
you have me and gabe and the podcast
also um we're a little late on bone of
the week because some of the stuff we've
been working on but i'm sure we'll have
it out this afternoon in the poll at d
tony michael's pot for bone end of the
week i'm sure vladimir putin is going to
make it on that boneheaded list
because we will do bonehead of the week
tomorrow i also think that rachel
bitkoffer you guys all know rachel is
going to be joining us talking about
cpac was the the thing that i really
wanted to question question her about
and what cpac actually is now and now
that max matt schlapp says that they're
not conservatives don't consider
themselves conservatives anymore
so why would they have a conservative
event the other thing i want to ask her
is why don't democrats have these these
these circle jerks i mean i think we
should i think we should i think we
should have these these um these events
where a lot of democrats can get
together they can get together under one
message i think it works um you know
everyone you know scoffs at the idea
that well we can't use what they can't
do what they do you absolutely can do
what they do you can do it with the
truth
why why can't you propagate the truth
why
why wouldn't we want to propagate the
truth in the first place why don't we
want to do that like over and over and
over again
and keep pounding the drum of truth
and then they pound the drum of lies so
the opposite is pounding the drum of
truth so we're not doing what they're
doing we're doing the opposite
that's what we try to do here on the
tony michaels podcast and the [ __ ] list
roundup
with the tweety tweets and attorney
trends again we're still waiting on
president biden here we have the c-span
have you guys ever watched c-span it's
sometimes it's boring
but sometimes
sometimes this stuff can get pretty good
let's listen now they're under they have
no water there at all
and this is the same reason yemen the
president is coming out let's um
let's listen to the president here and
let's uh make christmas
good afternoon
the russian military has begun a brutal
assault on the people of ukraine
without provocation without
justification
without necessity
this is a pre-meditated attack
vladimir putin has been planning this
for months is something that we've been
saying all along
he moved more than 175
000 troops military equipment and
positions along the ukrainian border
he moved blood supplies into position
and built a field hospital which tells
you all you need to know about his
intentions all along
he rejected every good faith effort the
united states and our allies and
partners made to address our mutual
security concerns
through dialogue to avoid needless
conflict and avert human suffering
for weeks for weeks we have been warning
that this would happen
and now
it's unfolding largely as we predicted
in the past week we've seen shelling
increase in the donbass a region in
eastern ukraine controlled by
russian-backed separatists
rush the russian government
has perpetrated cyber attacks against
ukraine
we saw a staged political theater in
moscow outlandish in baseless claims
that ukraine was a ukraine was about to
invade
and launch a war against russia
that ukraine was prepared to use
chemical weapons ukraine committed a
genocide
without any evidence
we saw a flagrant violation of
international law
in attempting to unilaterally create two
new so-called republics
on sovereign ukrainian territory
and at the very moment that the united
nations security council was meeting to
stand up for ukraine's sovereignty to
stave off invasion putin declared his
war
within moments moments
missile strikes began to fall on
historic cities across ukraine
then came the air raids
followed by tanks and troops rolling in
we've been transparent with the world
we've shared declassified evidence about
russia's plans and cyber attacks and
false pretext so that there could be no
confusion or cover-up about what putin
was doing
putin is the aggressor putin chose this
war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences
today i'm authorizing additional strong
sanctions
and new limitations on what can be
exported to russia
this is going to impose severe cost on
the russian economy both immediately and
over time
we have purposely designed these
sanctions to maximize the long-term
impact on russia and to minimize the
impact on the united states and our
allies
and i want to be clear
the united states is not doing this
alone
for months we've been building a
coalition of partners representing well
more than half the global economy
27 members of the european union
including france germany italy as well
as the united kingdom canada japan
australia new zealand and many others to
amplify the joint impact of our response
i just spoke with the g7 leaders this
morning
and we're in full and total agreement
we will limit russia's ability to do
business in dollars euros pounds and yen
to be part of the global economy will
limit their ability to do that
we're going to stunt the ability of to
finance and grow russia the russian
military
we're going to impose major and we're
going to impair their ability to compete
in high-tech 21st century economy
we've already seen the impact of our
actions on russia's currency in the
ruble
which
early today hit its weakest level ever
ever in history
the russia stock market plunged today
the russian government borrowing rates
spiked by over 15 percent
today's actions
we've now sanctioned russian banks that
together hold around one trillion
dollars in assets
we've cut off russia's largest bank a
bank that holds more than one-third of
russia's banking assets by itself
cut it off from the u.s financial system
and today we're also blocking four more
major banks
that means every asset they have in
america will be frozen
this includes vtb the second largest
bank in russia which has 250 billion
dollars in assets
as promised we're also adding the names
to the list of russian elites
and their family members
that are sanctioning that were
sanctioned as well
as i said on tuesday these are people
who personally gain from the kremlin's
policies and they should share in the
pain
we will keep up this drumbeat
of those designations against corrupt
billionaires in the days ahead
on tuesday
we stopped
from u.s or european investors
now we're going to apply the same
restrictions to russia's largest
state-owned enterprises
companies with assets that exceed 1.4
trillion dollars
some of the most powerful impacts our
actions will come over time
as we squeeze russians access to
finances and technology
for strategic sectors of its economy and
degrade its industrial capacity for
years to come
between our actions and those of our
allies and partners
we estimate that we'll cut off more than
half of russia's high-tech imports
they'll strike a blow to their ability
to continue to modernize their military
it'll degrade their aerospace industry
including their space program
it'll hurt their ability to build ships
reducing their ability to compete
economically
and it will be a major hit to putin's
long-term strategic ambitions
and we're preparing to do more
in addition to the economic penalties
we're imposing we're also taking steps
to defend our nato allies
particularly in the east
tomorrow
nato will convene a summit we'll be
there
to bring together the leaders of 30
allied nations
and close partners to affirm our
solidarity
and to map out the next steps we will
take to further strengthen all aspects
of our nato alliance
although we provided over 650 million
dollars in defensive assistance to
ukraine just this year
this last year
let me say it again
our forces are not
and will not be engaged in the conflict
with russia in ukraine
our forces are not going to europe to
fight in ukraine but to defend our nato
allies and reassure those allies in the
east
as i made crystal clear
the united states will defend every inch
of nato territory with the full force of
american power
and the good news is
nato is more united and more determined
than ever
there is no doubt
no doubt that the united states and
every nato ally will meet our article
five commitments
which says an attack on one as an attack
on all
over the past few weeks i ordered
thousands of additional forces to
germany and poland as part of our
commitment to nato
on tuesday
in response to russia's aggressive
action including his troop presence in
belarus and the black sea i've
authorized deployment of ground and air
forces already stationed in europe to
nato's eastern flank allies estonia
latvia lithuania poland and romania
our allies
have also been stepping up
adding the other allies the rest of nato
adding their own forces and capabilities
to ensure collective defense and today
within hours of russia's unleashing its
assault
nato came together and authorized and
activated an activation of response
plans
this will enable nato's high readiness
forces to deploy
and when and where they are needed to
protect our nato allies on the eastern
boundaries of europe
and now i'm authorizing additional u.s
force capabilities to deploy to germany
as part of nato's response including
some of the us-based forces that the
department of defense placed on standby
weeks ago
i've also spoken with defense secretary
austin and chairman of joint chiefs
general milley
about preparations for additional moves
should they become necessary to protect
our nato allies
and support the greatest military
alliance in the history of the world
nato
as we respond
my administration is using the tools
every tool at disposal protect american
families and businesses from rising
prices at the gas pump
you know we're taking active steps to
bring down the cost
and american oil and gas companies
should not should not exploit this
moment to hike their prices to raise
profits
you know in our sanctions package we
specifically designed to allow energy
payments to continue
we are closely monitoring energy
supplies for any disruption
we've been coordinating with major oil
producing and consuming countries toward
our common interest to secure global
energy supplies
we are actively working with countries
around the world to elevate collective
release from the strategic petroleum
reserves of major energy consuming
countries
and the united states will release
additional barrels of oil as conditions
worn
i know this is hard
and that americans are already hurting
i will do everything in my power to
limit the pain the american people are
feeling at the gas pump
this is critical to me
but this aggression cannot go unanswered
if it did the consequences for america
would be much worse
america stands up to bullies we stand up
for freedom
this is who we are
let me also repeat the warning i made
last week
if russia pursues cyber attacks against
our companies our critical
infrastructure we are prepared to
respond
for months we've been working closely
with our pride with the private sector
to harden our cyber defenses
sharpen our ability to respond to
russian cyber attacks as well
i spoke last night to president
zielinski of ukraine
and i assured him that the united states
together with our allies and partners in
europe will support the ukrainian people
as they defend their country
we'll provide you humanitarian relief to
ease their suffering
in the early days of this conflict
russia propaganda outlets will keep
trying to hide the truth and claim
success
for its military operation against a
made-up threat
but history has shown
time and again
how swift gains in territory
eventually give way to grinding
occupations
acts of mass civil mass civil
disobedience
and strategic dead ends
the next few weeks and months we hard on
the people of ukraine
putin has unleashed a great pain on them
but the ukrainian people have known 30
years of independence
they've repeatedly shown that they will
not tolerate anyone who tries to take
their country backwards
this is a dangerous moment for all of
europe
for the freedom around the world
putin has committed an assault on the
very principles that uphold the global
peace
but now
the entire world sees clearly what putin
and his criminal
and his kremlin allies are really all
about
this was never about a genuine security
concerns on their part
it was always about naked aggression
about putin's desire for empire
by any means necessary
by bullying russia's neighbors through
coercion and corruption
by changing borders by force
and ultimately by choosing a war without
a cause
putin's action betrays sinister vision
for the future of our world
one more nations take what they want by
force
but it is a vision that the united
states and freedom-loving nations
everywhere will oppose with every tool
of our considerable power
the united states and our allies and
partners will merge from this stronger
more united more determined and more
purposeful
and putin's aggression
against ukraine will end up costing
russia dearly
economically and strategically
we will make sure of that
putin will be a pariah on the
international stage
any nation accountant as russia's naked
aggression against ukraine will be
stained by association
when the history of this era is written
putin's choice
to make a totally unjustifiable war on
ukraine will have russia weaker
and the rest of the world stronger
liberty democracy human dignity these
are the forces far more powerful
than fear and oppression
they cannot be extinguished by tyrants
like putin and his armies
they cannot be erased by people from
people's hearts and hopes by any amount
of violence and intimidation
they endure
in the contest between democracy and
autocracy
between sovereignty and subjugation
make no mistake
freedom will prevail
god bless the people of a free and
democratic ukrainian may god protect our
troops
[Music]
associated press zeke
i'm sorry sorry sorry i guess i had my
mic muted my mic was muted uh sorry
about that
okay so back back to business uh thanks
for joining us today um we we've seen
that president uh biden gave his remarks
on putin in the uh war in ukraine here
um and the tyrant as known as putin
thanks for joining us i appreciate you
guys staying with us even though we
moved the interview again um
we found it very important today to to
move the interview and have uh coverage
on ukraine and we felt it very very very
very important today so don't forget
we're gonna have the bone end of the
week um uh poll up today uh hopefully
sometime today i'm i'm i would guess
that uh a murderous dictator would work
his way on the bonehead of the week poll
so go follow at tonymichael's pod go
vote there um tony michael's pod and
follow me at the tony michaels and go
follow gabe at i am gabe sanchez give us
some support there also if you like to
support the podcast you can go to
thetonymichaels.com
and you can go to the podcast upgrade
fund or you can get you some [ __ ]
merch there's all kinds of [ __ ] merch
i'm also subscribed to the youtube
channel and hit the like button and go
to the other videos and watch the other
videos and comment down below whatever
the hell i'm supposed to say about the
youtube um whatever it is that i'm
supposed to say about youtube you go do
that and then we'll both be satisfied
thank you for joining us today again on
the johnny michaels podcast and the [ __ ]
list roundup
we had a lot of fun today we had a lot
of fun
even though we were talking about some
very important subjects um i hope you
guys found some of this
i hope you guys found some of the
information that we showed today uh very
critical in the steps that are leading
up to uh putin's demise here i believe
that's ultimately what we're going to
see so that's that is what happens
to tyrants
that's what happens this this here is is
tyrant 101 um and it's great to see that
we have an
uh in america we have a president who is
pro-democracy i don't know if you listen
to his message um but you know and i i
don't talk to the president on a regular
basis
but if i did
i would tell him my messaging that i say
every single day
and it seems as if
that message maybe not through me but
through others
is starting to break through and find
its way into a speech about a war that a
tyrant is trying to ensue on the entire
world and democracy itself
so stay tuned tomorrow again why
bonehead of the week in the second hour
uh rachel bitkoffer i think is going to
join us in the first hour i hope i hope
we can connect with rachel um she's
going to talk about cpac and why the
democrats don't have a a type of circle
jerk like cpac is to boost our messaging
i think we should do that we have to do
that we have to continue to keep
boosting our message
and until tomorrow
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events in political news no
rules no boundaries i think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking